[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue
c'est parti pour 50 minutes de débat
alors vous participez point de vue sur
twitter sur lefigaro.fr voici le
sommaire de l'émission d'abord la
démission du numéro un de force ouvrière
est une question sous-jacente
cette crise a efforts révèle-t-elle un
syndicalisme à bout de souffle à bout de
souffle et ne l'était pas mais à bout de
nerfs oui les têtières jean luc
mélenchon éructant lors d'une
perquisition au siège de la france
insoumise aujourd'hui il est interrogé
sur le fond par les enquêteurs son
audition est terminée depuis une heure
nous vous posons la question le leader
de la france a soumise cette île
disqualifié par ses outrances des
outrances il y en art dans les
universités américaines où le
politiquement correct gagne partout du
terrain
on verra ensemble si les triggers
morning lsf space 2 qui envahissent
harvard ou yale peuvent bientôt franchir
l'atlantique
enfin vous débourserez peut-être bientôt
2 euros 50 pour traverser la place de la
concorde remonté la canebière ou longer
la place bellecour il sera en effet
bientôt possible pour les mères
d'instaurer des péages urbains on verra
si c'est une bonne idée
bonjour renée fregosi mère ses frères
gauzy pardon vous merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes philosophe une
arrière universitaire votre cursus
personnel mentionne votre adhésion au
mlf
dès l'âge de 16 ans et votre
compagnonnage avec le parti socialiste
tendance bloom est il précisé et vous
êtes l'auteur des nouveaux autoritaire
c'est paru en 2016 auditions aux
éditions du moment
bonjour alexandra la faille merci nous
avoir rejoints vous allez travailler
dans plusieurs sociétés grands groupes
avant de fonder le think tank si nokia
et vous êtes l'auteur ça remonte à août
reprenons le pouvoir un manifeste pour
notre droit à être bien gouverner
sept programmes bonjour cécile crouzet
le journaliste au service macro économie
du figaro
vous êtes aussi l'auteur aujourd'hui
d'un excellent papier très documenté sur
la crise un sport chrono hier depuis six
mois on va en parler
et bonjour génie bastié journaliste au
service débat opinion du figaro membres
de la revue limite revue bio
conservatrice décroissante et
d'inspiration chrétienne et il résumé et
vous êtes l'auteur du le port émissaire
terreur ou contre révolution le port per
c'est paru auxerre c'est tout récent
c'était en septembre voilà alors on
parle tout de suite de notre premier
sujet les syndicats la démission forcée
de pascal pavageau patron ex patron de
force ouvrière révèle un climat délétère
au sein d'organisations syndicales mais
elles signent aussi lente décomposition
de ce paysage syndical syndicats qui au
fil des années perdre des adhérents et
du poids sans doute dans les
négociations un lent déclin un lent
déclin kg était ce matin à demi avoué
par un autre leader laurent berger
secrétaire général de la cfdt on écoute
ce qui se passe ne fait pas de bien au
syndicalisme notamment quand on voit un
certain nombre de délits toria liste de
deux commentateurs qui explique que tout
ça est la révélation du mal profond du
syndicalisme français sans distinction
alors ce mal profond vous décrivez très
bien c'est si cause elle évidemment
appliqué à force ouvrière dans votre
papier ce matin vous expliquer les
affrontements entre les lignes
réformiste et radicale l'autoritarisme
de des leaders et notamment de pascal
pavageau le fonctionnement quasi
sectaire
force ouvrière va dans le mur et emporte
avec elle les autres syndicats première
question et la réponse est sur un peu
différente force ouvrière haut et en
très très grande difficulté parce qu'il
se retrouve sans leader fort gênant à
quelques semaines une élection très
importante pour eux qui est celle des
dans la fonction publique où les
fonctionnaires ont choisir leurs
représentants et de l'état les bois 17
des poids des syndicats sachant que pour
fo la fonction publique
vraiment capital ils sont le numéro un
au sein de la fonction publique d'état
donc ça vous retombe extrêmement mal
pour eux et en plus ils sont
effectivement très divisée sachant où
aller et est numéro un dans le privé et
elle vise la place de numéro un mais
deux minutes après la situation un peu
différente à la cfdt qu'elle est un
corpus idéologique beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup vous marquer beaucoup plus
alignés et tout ce qui était un peu trop
contestataire ou qu'ils étaient prêts à
peu plus dans un peu trop ce qu'ils sont
et est éliminé il ya fort longtemps donc
il ya quand même voilà et la cgt elle
même est dans une autre position encore
à elle seule espèce de l'an effritement
aussi un espèce de repli sur une ligne
très dur très voilà très très très
contestataire et c'est un espèce de d'un
fait cela en interne afin de disputer
blond d'évitement dans ses bastions
d'edf de la sncf etc où elle perd grève
après grève être père albert les combats
les uns après les autres et où elle
s'effrite lentement mais sûrement
donc chacun et simplicité mais
globalement les mouvements n'est quand
même pas véritablement en abstention et
anne on aurait dit c'est sûr finalement
ils ont encore une forme de légitimité
ces syndicats oui mais vous avez bon
c'est c'est une question ancienne à la
question des syndicats mais vous les
avez très bien décrit les syndicats
français sont extrêmement politisé la
scission entre la cgt fo c'est lorsque
les communistes sont devenus
majoritaires
grâce à l'appui d'ailleurs des
gaullistes à la libération sains et donc
les anticommunistes
ceci a listé ancien archos home ont fait
scission de la majorité qui était devenu
communiste stalinienne à l'époque donc
le syndicalisme français malgré ses
déclarations est extrêmement politisée
donc on assiste à la crise aussi des
partis politiques à travers les meubles
sarah l'air juste mais aussi la crise du
salariat donc c'est ça saigne beaucoup
de choses ensemble
elle faillit finalement est ce que
manuel macron à leurs raisons dans la
première partie de sa prison de
légiférer par ordonnances et au bout du
compte de se passer de passer outre
bonne partie les syndicats il y avait
une priorité pour lui c'était de faire
passer un certain nombre de dispositions
rapidement ça corresponde à sa stratégie
c'était sa logique est-ce que c'était
une bonne logique j'en sais rien la
logique qui consiste à dire on va
gouverner tout seul un vieux grand pays
comme la france c'est pas forcément
astucieux la logique de l'état ou du
chef de l'état s'est pas naître le
l'homme qui dirige tout qui décide de
tout c'est plutôt d'être un facilitateur
de quelqu'un qui va aider à faire
prendre des décisions qui va jouer le
collectif il n'a pas joué comme ça c'est
pas un cadeau offert aux syndicats lors
de nos syndicats sont très loin de ce
que la crise qu'il traverse et la même
crise que les partis politiques c'est
une vraie crise de l'egypte de
représentativité et donc du fait de
légitimité et on voit bien que il ne
représente plus qu'un petit corps du
monde du travail et que ce monde du
travail qui est complètement en voie de
transformation n'a pas de représentant
aujourd'hui
or on est on revient presque au xixème
siècle humeur c'est un retour à la case
dix neuvième avec finalement le des
travailleurs indépendants qui sont
exploités par des grosses structures et
qui pour l'instant ne sont pas fédérer
alors est-ce qu'il vous seront fédérés
demain ou après-demain et par quoi et
comment il faut le souhaiter
parce qu'il faut bien quand même qu'à un
moment donné y ait des négociations
liées des représentants mais ces
syndicats là les a connus tels qu'on les
a connus ne représente plus finalement
qu'une base qui est pour partie basse
public et puis un peu du monde privée
mais plutôt grand grandes entreprises et
qui ne parlent pas vraiment au nom des
salariés et à qui parle encore moins aux
ceux qui sont en dehors du monde
travaillent ils sont au chômage
donc ces syndicats là ils ont vocation à
se transformer ou à disparaître ils
seront remplacés
il faut souhaiter nerfs pour revenir sur
ce qu'il a dit
ma faille génie finalement
c'est un contrepoids utiles les
syndicats c'est vrai ce que vous disiez
on peut donc finalement ça peut être
problématique aussi d'être complètement
avec deux mondes qui ne se parlent pas
et qu'il ya c'est encore intermédiaires
qui fasse le lien
moi je pense que les corps
intermédiaires sont indispensables dans
une démocratie et que évidemment les
syndicats en font partie et aujourd'hui
dans une société quand même que de plus
en plus atomisé d'où justement il n'y a
rien entre l'état et l'individu il ya
plus y'a plus rien il ya l'état d'un
côté tout puissant et les arrivées
individus atomisés de l'autre et et je
pense qu'on manque justement de
structures intermédiaires que ce soit
associative les corporations les
syndicats et on a une faiblesse
structurelle en france aussi qui est dû
à cette espèce de d'étatisme très très
fort qui fait que nos syndicats enfin on
a un poids un problème les corps
intermédiaires et donc je crois oui que
c'est qu'il est nécessaire le problème
c'est en effet que les syndicats en
france sont extrêmement politisé et qui
sont une force aujourd'hui qu'une force
de citadelles assiégées c'est à dire il
ne propose rien ils sont juste dans le
nom à dire à refuser les réformes et à
ne pas proposer d'alternative et on
al'impression vraiment qu'ils sont un
final est d appeler les prébendiers
d'akiyo obsolètes qui ne qui sont comme
ça à conserver sur leurs concerts leurs
acquis mais qui n'ont plus une force de
transformation sociale tel qu'il avait
pu l'être auparavant
cécile sur ce point comment quel peut
être le nouveau visage de alors comment
les appeler je ne sais pas syndicats
corps intermédiaires associations de la
france des années 2050 de tout cas pas
évident à dire après il ya des syndicats
inquiets qu'est ce qu'ils savaient quand
même réfléchir à la près à ce nouveau
monde du travail et sert à part c'est
particulièrement c'est davantage vrai
ceux qui sont étiquetés réformiste fdt
cftc etc ils essayent 1 il ya quand même
du travail qui est fait de deux fédérer
même les travailleurs hubert qui sont
voilà de tout ça mais c'est pas évident
pour eux en tout cas c'est vital de se
transformer et puis je pense
effectivement pour la société on a
absolument besoin de corps
intermédiaires parce que s'il n'y a pas
effectué de régulateurs sociaux
qu'est ce qui va se passer quand il ya
une grosse social ça explose dans tous
les sens donc ça c'est la terreur et
d'ailleurs pour ces concerts aussi que
pas mal de chefs d'entreprise au medef
poutine afin qu'ils ne veulent pas la
disparition de syndicats parce qu'il n'y
a rien de pire dans une entreprise assez
importante de n'avoir personne
interlocuteurs et n'aura comme
interlocuteur structure est malgré tout
on aime ou on n'aime pas relativement
fort mais vu rudik mhand formés à la
négociation formés aux enjeux etc
et puis on va se retrouver avec qui avec
n'importe quel groupuscule
communautariste n'importe quel prix
puisque politique en face à ccc pour une
entreprise pme c'est un peu différent
mais pour une entreprise de taille
correcte c'est vrai et ça serait en moi
ça restera aussi en même temps peut-être
ponctuel mais deux personnes de
leadership d'un système car on a vu les
problèmes de tirer le port à la cgt
aujourd'hui de pascal pavageau
sans présumer de leurs de ses affaires
mais elles sont pas judiciaire n'en
bouclé mais ça pose quand même quelques
questions sur est ce qu'on est capable
de produire des leaders là encore c'est
le même problème que l'on a eue avec
dans la vie politique française
là que les systèmes ont parfois du mal à
se renouveler pour des bonnes et des
mauvaises raisons parmi les mauvaises
raisons alors je connais moins le cas
des syndicats mais on l'a beaucoup vu
dans la sphère politique ou ceux qui
sont dedans ceux qui tiennent les postes
s'organisent pour les conserver et en
faisant le vide autour d'eux donc si
vous n'avez pas du tout le principe
d'une méritocratie qui permet de faire
émerger des temps ça marche au niveau
des circonscriptions
vous avez un député bart on danse a
circle et puis globalement ils tuent
tous les mecs pas mal autour de lui et
il garde que les moins bons de manière
être certain d jamais renversé et c'est
comme ça que vous avez des scènes qui
parfois ces fonds de bascule mais
pendant vingt ou trente ans ils sont
conservés par les mêmes quoi et ça
marche c'est ce genre de principe
montclam relativement très haut dans la
sphère politique
je pense que le syndicalisme n'échappe
pas à ça après il ya des questions de
chapelle on le voit également medef de
pouvoir de contre-pouvoir de faiseur de
roi et au bout du compte ce n'est pas
toujours celui qui est le meilleur c'est
souvent enfin c'est à dire devenir trial
c'est un peu c'est un peu collante à
quoi c'est que celui qui gagne n'est pas
forcément le plus compétente plus sympa
le plus beau le plus le plus efficace
est celui qui arrive à faire le plus de
combinés qui va finalement éliminer ses
adversaires au bon moment mais c'est pas
le meilleur qui gagne c'est pas le
meilleur au centre d'intérêt général et
sur les syndicats moi je suis très
frappé en fait de l'arrivée de monsieur
pavageau en fait c'était comme une
réponse à l'arrivée de maquereaux c'est
à dire y mène le lac rond plutôt
président de droite et on lui met
quelqu'un qui fait un qui vraiment
qu'ils ramènent fo très à gauche on est
vraiment très loin d'eux
pour ceux qui s'en souviennent autour de
cette table on n'est peut-être pas très
nombreux mais des gens comme andré
bergeron par exemple voilà on était
vraiment dans la négociation
contractuelle
on est dans météo toujours delà des gens
qui avait du poids mais qui avait aussi
envie d'aller de l'avant quoi
aujourd'hui on est dans des discours
politiques suffit d'y cours d'écouté ce
que et monsieur pavageau c'est
extrêmement brutal
on est dans la caricature on est
beaucoup plus dans la vie politique
finalement que dans la vie syndicale et
du combat militant au sens progrès
social du terme ça pose un problème au
pouvoir si on disait entrepris de chat
qui amène avoir des interlocuteurs
gouvernement là il fait comment abbas a
posé un problème enfin oui oui donc à
court terme c'est sûr de pascal pavageau
ce n'était pas la tasse de thé
voilà du gouvernement il l'a déjà été en
position frontale après on sait pas du
tout ce qui va émerger qui va émerger
donc bon c'est quand même très il faut
que les trotskistes et les réformistes
entendre qu'ils ont fait pour dégager
pas chaud mais ça s'est passé de 2 pour
dégager maintenant pour retrouver
quelqu'un d'autre ça va être un peu
compliqué il égalisa alors est ce qu'il
ya quelqu'un à peu quant au chant espèce
de deux milieux moyens moyennant qui est
pas beaucoup de pouvoir
qu'ils soient aux mains des courants et
qu'on se rassemble sur un peu niña ces
contestataires parce que c'est le seul
le dénominateur commun le minimum quoi
passer un concours on voit beaucoup de
la dent d'en sortir l'info qui donnera
une force de proposition dans ces
conditions ça devient difficile
alors à la question qu'on vous pose sur
twitter en pleine crise penser à frères
s'offrir pensez vous que le syndicalisme
soit à bout de souffle et bien vous êtes
sans beaucoup de surprise qu'entre 23 %
de nos internautes à répondre que feint
de ne pas répondre que oui le
syndicalisme est à bout de souffle et
par ailleurs nous avons pas encore de
questions sur ce sujet mais je ne peux
que vous conseiller si ce n'est encore
fait la lecture de ce papier cette
enquête de cécile qui fait le le point
très bien et très de façon très
pédagogique sur force ouvrière et la
crise qui sévit depuis plusieurs mois je
vous propose maintenant de parler de
jean luc mélenchon difficile d'y
échapper cette semaine le leader de la
france a soumises étaient convoqués donc
ce matin pour être entendus dans les
deux enquêtes ouvertes celles sur ses
comptes de campagne et celle sur ses
assistants parlementaires
alors même s'il était plus calme qu'hier
pendant la perquisition jean luc
mélenchon reste sur sa ligne de
victimisation
voici ce qu'il a dit c'était ce matin
avant d'entrer dans les locaux de la
police judiciaire à nanterre locaux dont
il est d'ailleurs sorti il y a à peu
près une heure on écoute donc on est
dans une opération de police politique
qui est nulle et qui va évidemment
échoué parce qu'elle est pourri de vices
de procédure de toutes sortes et parce
qu'elle n'a aucun sens et je me présente
tout à fait tranquille car le ridicule
va être du côté de ceux qu on déployait
tous ses moyens pour rien
alors rené fregosi illégaux tout
simplement la question composé les
griots par jean luc mélenchon avec cette
séquence
vous savez s'il y avait des élections
demain oui probablement ça lui serait
préjudiciable mais ça sera oublié quand
même dans quelques temps parce que en
plus il est coutumier du fait donc on
sait qu'ils s'énervent beaucoup il fait
beaucoup de cinéma
non mais ce qui est ce qui est plus
grave c'est effectivement cette remise
en cause de la justice mais d'un autre
côté pour ne pas dire en même temps
c'est vrai que là certains juges se
prennent parfois pour des justiciers
donc ça pose aussi un problème parce que
bon lorsque la journaliste posait la
question à mélenchon mais enfin il ya
d'autres cas dans d'autres partis et
c'est vrai moi je n'aurais jamais voté
fillon mais j'ai trouvé ça scandaleux la
façon dont ça s'est passé
le pendant la campagne électorale et est
mobilisée plus loin de là
ma politique derrière et politique le
problème c'est que c'est pas un parti
politique qui est derrière c est vrai qu
il ya quelque chose comme mais ce ne
sont pas tous les juges mais il y a
quelques juges qui effectivement se
prennent pour des justiciers c'est à
dire à mon avis outrepasse le le rôle du
juge et et donc ils font de la politique
mais pas au nom d'un parti politique
c'est pas tel ou tel parti qui attaquent
tel autre mais c'est justement étant
donné cette déliquescence du monde
politique cet affaiblissement des partis
en général vous avez certains juges qui
se prennent pour des justiciers moi j'ai
cette notion de justicialiste mais elle
est très répandue l'appliquer à la
sphère qui nous occupe depuis début de
la semaine avec sans mal avec cette
analyse de renée fregosi je crois que
quand on regarde les vingt dernières
années les partis politiques les
syndicats étudiants enfin pratiquement
tout le monde a subi la justice à droite
à gauche voilà quand un moment donné par
ces mois les roadshows changé il n'y a
pas de alors il peut y avoir un peu
d'acharnement de temps en temps ça peut
savait qu'on peut le considérer jeudi on
peut le considérer après c'est à la
justice de dire à la fin quand elle rend
justice si acharnement ou pas comme on
verra ce qui ne remet pour madame le pen
on verra ce qu'il en est pour monsieur
fillon on verra ce qu'il en est
maintenant pour monsieur mélenchon
mégère globalement il n'y a pas un
ciblage particulier l'effet qu'une
police politique homme s'était dit je
crois pas que ce soit le coeur ça j'ai
dit ça j'y crois pas un instant
alors après sur monsieur mélenchon pour
répondre à votre question on ne revienne
à oui effectivement à la question
initiale qui était ce qui s'écrit très
sincèrement moi je ne sais pas si les
grilles et je pense que vivent et de sa
base électorale
il restera toujours convaincant parce
que derrière ils sont passés de l'autre
côté la ligne sont pas encore récupéré
si je puis dire sur un système politique
quelques voilà enfin il n'est pas dans
le camp des des parties des partis de
gouvernement aujourd'hui mais j'ai eu
raison plus que quand on voit monsieur
mélenchon l'usagé qu'il fait de son
impunité
on imagine à un peut très bien imaginer
l'image qui fera usage qui fera du
pouvoir si demande donne les clés c'est
terrifiant gl 4 ans c'est d'autant plus
dangereuse qu'en plus on a vu la
servilité du bonhomme face à emmanuel
macron dire qu' il est très fort par
rapport au faible et dès qu'ils les
fassent mention à la séquence est vite
évidemment aidé qui les fasse dès qu'ils
les fassent alors pas par rapport aux 0
2 hier par rapport avec les caméras
vis-à-vis d'un policier vise à vide d'un
avis procure là il va jouer les gros
bras parce qu'il sait qu'il est en
position de force mais par contre
vis-à-vis de mes nouvelles macro ou
qu'il aurait pu le lire oui monsieur le
président vous avez des postures qui
sont de nature xénophobe et j'apprécie
pas ce que vous faites le que c'est pas
bien
là ils s'écrasent comme une carpe est
donc si vous l'avez type est non
seulement un lâche
et en plus on y fait un usage abusif de
son pouvoir donc moi j'ai dit j'espère
que ce pays ne lui confiera jamais les
clés du pauvre ça va lui coller à la
peau cécile autres à vivre ça renforce
l'image qu'il a d'être quelqu'un des
reptiles fait pas très qui ne se contre
qui se maîtrise pas totalement donc
sacré je pense à créer un lien il est
aimé par sa mère il ya une sorte de
plafond de verre par soit un plafond de
verre ou en une enceinte de sécurité un
petit peu il ya un plafond qu'il arrive
pas à crever à cause de genre de
comportement et ça ça alimente à nouveau
ce cette impression que c'est quelqu'un
qui se maîtrise pas tellement qu'il est
qu'il ya aussi des petits comme un
soucis vis-à-vis de la démocratie enfin
personne n'est au dessus des lois il ya
des ya des protections pour les
parlementaires mais sont quand même
circonstance il c'est sur la garde à vue
sur les actifs relèvent de leur mandat
donc au droit du tout on y va parce qu
on est parlementaire n'est pas du tout
eu les lois forte heureusement
d'ailleurs sinon on serait pas du tout
une démocratie et la façon à imaginer un
seul instant qu'un citoyen lambda se
comporte comme ça avec des policiers ou
des procureurs régime ans de prison oui
passé c'est pas franchement enfin vous
et moi ils pourront insultant un
policier le bouscule on est inadmissible
fait je sais c'est un souci pour la
démocratie
je alors effectivement on disait il
c'est peut-être un peu calmé jean luc
mélenchon en sortant il a continué quand
même sur la même veine
c'est un traquenard at il dit c'est une
opération de police politique
cinq heures pour enfoncer des portes
ouvertes
moi ya aussi quelque chose qui m'a
frappé dans les propos qu'on a passé
tout à l'heure il dit c'est une
opération de police qui est nulle et qui
va échouer parce qu'elle est pourri de
vices de procédure c'est un homme c'est
quand on analyse sur le fond il n'y va
pas et 10 et des vices de procédure qui
fait savoir qu'il est attaqué pour deux
choses jean luc mélenchon d'ailleurs
c'est toujours la même chose dans tous
les partis politiques ces
surfacturations et emploi fictif
si souvent des hommes d'affaires
surfacturation c'était bygmalion emplois
fictifs c'était fillon sur facturations
de décompte de grandes campagnes
notamment à la société média scop tenu
par ce final shigeru l'une de ses
proches et emploi fictif avec débat les
assistants du parlement européen qu'il
aurait utilisée pour son parti à paris
et non pas avec l'argent boxell donc
c'est toujours les mêmes mots les mêmes
turpitudes dans tous les partis ça se
retrouve en effet du front national à
mélenchon en passant par le modem par en
marche avec la fin ferrand c'était un
conflit d'intérêts mais enfin il ya
aucun parti qui échappe c'est ça c'est
certain
après je suis je pense qu'il ya un
soupçon qui pèse sur la justice en
france sur l'indépendance de la justice
et ce soupçon il est en partie justifiée
quand on apprend par exemple il ya trois
semaines
le 6 mai le monde qui a fait katy serait
là dessus sur le fait que macro aurait
lui même insisté pour nommer le
successeur de françois l'eau au moulin à
paris en tant que procureur et le monde
à l'ua 10 titres et lui-même l'elysée
prend la main sur la justice et sur le
parquet bon on sait qu'il ya un problème
d'indépendance du parquet en france et
je crois que voilà ce soupçon là il ne
sera pas levé tant qu' on en aura pas
une justice totalement dépendantes en
france et tant que le pouvoir politique
ne cessera pas d'alimenter en tout cas
ce sont peut-être qu'il ya dans le cas
de mélenchon effectivement c'est la
justice qui suit son cours mais ce
soupçon et sept arrières font finalement
de non indépendance de la justice laisse
laisse le champ libre à plein de théorie
alors on va peut-être pas ouvrir le
débat sur l'indépendance du parquet la
voilà qui est compliqué juste c'est vrai
que emmanuel macron à rayer les noms qui
a été proposé par le conseil supérieur
la magistrature bc2 ses prérogatives de
ce qu'ils ne trouvent pas se passe à sa
fonction comment le nom le nord de paris
beaucoup de liens incestueux dans la
république française qui ne sont pas que
les liens entre le pouvoir et la justice
entre globalement le pouvoir et tout ce
qui tourne autour il ya toujours voilà
entre les grands corps les conjoints
voilà non mais c'est vrai que tout ça
crée ses sources eurent surtout ça c'est
en question voilà c'est surtout ça parce
que je pense que globalement les
institutions font leur job mais à
l'intérieur il ya des gens qui sont trop
proches les uns des autres avec des
règles de déontologie qui sont pas
qu'ils sont pas claires et donc on
tolère des choses qu'on tolère dans
aucun autre pays de grands pays
européens ou même aux états unis alors
là ce qu'on fait en france ils nous
regardent comme des femmes restait enfin
la justice aussi un autre système
institutionnel c'est un choix qui a été
fait en france que le parquet ne soit
pas indépendante
j'en viens j'y reviens quand même avec
quelques commentaires de nos de nos
internautes et lattes qui nous dit
mélenchon a outrepassé ses droits si la
république ne peut plus s'appuyer sur
une juste sur une justice indépendante
alors elle cesse d'exister
monsieur babineau mélenchon a perdu ses
nerfs mais il a toujours été outrancier
sa base ne sera pas affaiblie et il
poursuit mélenchon soeur sur la vague de
la persécution judiciaire avec le pen et
fillon persécution
10 hier je lui laisse donc la
responsabilité de saut de son
commentaire et nicole qui ajoute aussi
s'en donner raison à mélenchon voudrait
voir la même diligence quand ce sont la
république en marche ou le modem qui
sont concernés ça revient effectivement
fréquemment dans vos commentaires
une question aussi peut-être de femmes
en politique alexandra la faille on a
peu entendu françois ruffin prendre la
défense de jean luc mélenchon un petit
peu mais de votre chez vous voyez
quelque chose se profiler donc ça de la
france a soumise à surveillance en
lui-même qui le dit il n'y a pas de
ligne du parti il ya globalement des
individualités qui s'est exprimé il ya
quelques lignes rouges qu'il faut pas
franchir pour le reste les gens
fonctionnent comme ils veulent
sanctionner après au quotidien je pense
que c'est compliqué être avec jean luc
mélenchon
je pense que pour une personnalité comme
françois ruffin sans doute est-ce pas
simple de se situer il a son propre
agenda on l'a vu d'ailleurs il est
capable d'être extrêmement extrêmement
capables d'être très sûr le veut la
problématique de la loi sur le handicap
il ya eu un amendement qui a été rejetée
par les parlementaires de république en
marche là il a fait un buzz incroyable
je pense qu'il a sa propre vie je pense
qu'il n'est pas dans le même schéma que
et le peut-être même la finalité
d'engagement que jean luc bergeon après
il faut gérer le temps long dire qu'il
ya peut-être un agenda aussi à deux
temps le temps long c'est quoi c'est
jean luc mélenchon fera pas un prochain
tour à la présidentielle donc abandonné
peut-être qu'il faut prendre ses
distances pour préparer une prochaine et
cette séquence c'est une hypothèse mais
tout est possible
alors la question qu on vous posait
toujours sur lefigaro.fr l'avs
face à cette perquisition et aux
réactions de jean luc mélenchon êtes
vous choqué par sa réaction à ces propos
vous êtes 74% à répondre oui eh bien
écoutez on va passer donc à notre thème
suivant le thème suivant il est question
des campus américains alors le figaro a
publié c'est un sujet pour vous au génie
le figaro a publié cette semaine une
interview d'un avocat sur le
politiquement correct dans les facs
américaines
son nom c'est greg loukianov alors c'est
vous qui avez réalisé cette interview au
génie j'essaye de la résumer rapidement
il est question de l'apparition d'une
nouvelle culture sur les campus
américains culture dont le but est de
purger les cours les débats de toute
idée mots ou sujets susceptibles
d'offenser les étudiants étudiants
étudiantes devrait chuter de dire ce qui
revient à censurer tout ce qui peut
heurter alors par exemple on ne peut
plus dire à quelqu'un on devrait plus
dire à quelqu'un qu'il parle par exemple
très bien anglais parce que cela
sous-entend qu'il n'est pas un actif
américain qui n'est pas un vrai
américain c'est à peu près ça pour
essayer de donner un exemple concret est
ce que ça peut donner
je vous donne pas tout de suite la
parole au génie parce que je suis est
intarissable sur le sujet renée fregosi
fregosi ça vous choque
vous qui êtes féministe cette tendance
du politiquement correct
ah oui absolument parce que c'est pas du
tout ma conception du féminisme c'est
pas un féminisme puritains que je
défends depuis que je suis tout jeune
c'est un féminisme de la libération
sexuelle de la liberté des moeurs et de
la libre pensée de la libre disposition
de son corps ce qui est pas du tout le
cas
à mon sens des néo féministes comme
jeudi
mais vous savez ces passionnés que ses
pairs dédié aux féministes lâchons pas
du tout ce qu'on a aimé mais ce
politiquement correct il fait pas
seulement aux états unis hélas il est
aussi dans les universités françaises
jeu pour être quelque peu égal que avec
par exemple des exemples qui me touchent
directement par exemple vous n'avez pas
le droit de dire que personne
le leader populiste argentin des années
50 spécialistes a été la porte d'entrée
des nazis
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
mon article eh bien je n'ai pas pu le
passer dans la revue de mon université
il va paraître prochainement aux temps
modernes mais parce que lanzmann juste
avant de mourir là lui a plu et donc il
sera publié mais parce que je n'ai pas
le droit d'attaquer le péronisme parce
que je fais des liens aussi avec le
péronisme d'aujourd'hui par exemple mais
c'est un débat merci terminaux mais mais
mais mais oui 6 non mais c'est du
cauchemar voir et on aime ça
c'est à dire que en tous les cas il ya
des thèmes qui sont un terreau dabou qui
sont à bout mais ça on le sait bien il
ya le thème de l'immigration c'est tabou
le mail on parle le plus me semble il ya
des délinquants à leurs demandes sur les
côtés oui mais ça c'était un avis et on
n'est même pas dans le contenu des
études on est dans le vivre ensemble
pour oui mais c'est aussi les mots qu'on
emploie voyez moi quand je je parle de
la traite négrière
il faut que j'explique que c'est un
concept que je ne traite pas les noirs
de [ __ ] la très près les wings en
galère ce concept et je dois alors
expliqué je vous donne la parole
expliquez-nous un peu plus ce qu'il en
ressort
et en quoi ça peut ac et non en fait le
livre de monsieur nokia n'a donc lui qui
lui est un avocat qui n'est pas un
universitaire et qu'un avocat
spécialiste de la défense du premier
amendement sur la liberté d'expression
notamment sur les campus
il défend les professeurs qui sont
attaquées ou les étudiants qui sont
attaqués au nom de cette défense qui est
très importante aux états unis la
liberté d'expression et il explique
qu'une nouvelle censure émergent qui ne
provient pas de l'état où
l'administration mais des étudiants
eux-mêmes et finalement qui émerge vous
parle pas du campus ils appellent ça de
codling il reprend le titre dans
ça va mais ça veut dire le chouchoutage
de l'esprit américain et comment fait on
essaie d'évacuer tout vexations possible
toute manière d'être au fond c est ce
que ça vaut son est en fait c'est une
sorte c'est spécieuse par exemple et on
peut appeler c'est un endroit où qu'un
étudiant sera entre guillemets sécurité
certain d'être en sécurité mais voilà il
sait pas et c'est plus la sécurité
physique c'est la sécurité même mental
et moral et intégré sera pas voilà et
donc les belles et par exemple et
professeurs doivent suivre des
formations pour avoir le droit de coller
sur leur bureau une étiquette sybase il
ya également ce qu'on appelle les
traders warning donc ces messages
avertissant au début des cours par
exemple quand on a étudié par exemple la
traite négrière der garde barwa parler
de colonisation attention on va enlever
être question de viol dans ce court et
c'est donc une espèce de raie du est
derrière lui c'est le spectre est bien
c'est que ce qui est dangereux c'est
qu'à une médicalisation de la liberté
d'expression en dix ans finalement c'est
la fameuse expression les mots tus
l'idée que finalement les mots la pensée
pourrait faire souffrir psychiquement
des élèves parce qu'ils entendent et
traumatisés parce qu'ils entendent des
choses
lorelei l'aï dit il ya vraiment une
dérive parce que non seulement c'est
faux mais en fait il est lui-même dit
que il a fait une corrélation avec les
dépressions voilà oui dieu lui même dit
que il est suivi par une thérapie pour
ont dépassé celles des pointes dépressif
d'ailleurs il le dit lui même il dit
mais c'est sa reine ne pas parler quand
on a des problèmes c'est pas si l'abonné
en plus vous y allez sur l'iss plus la
plus mauvaise solution quand on a été
traumatisé c'est ne jamais plus jamais
reparlé du stroma sous peine d'être
c'est un fait ça il dit que ça sert à ça
renforce les traumatismes au lieu de les
évacuer
puisqu'on refuse d'en parler ça devient
tabou etc et il dit que sur les campus
américains le taux de
deux suisses et envie de suicide a
énormément augmenté que les cellules
psychologiques ont augmenté donc ça crée
un mal-être sur la santé mentale des
étudiants qui est préoccupant plutôt que
justement leur donner à des outils de
résilience ou de pain manière de voilà
de rebondir on les encourage dans ce
trauma et donc au delà de ça c'est aussi
une perte de la liberté d'expression
c'est celle renée fregosi nous disait
c'est déjà le cas en france
vous avez aussi l'idée que ça peut
arriver très vite et nous envahir
on est quand même dans des cultures
assez différente mais c'est vrai qu'un
en fait oui il ya une espèce de ya des
sujets va comme dans toute société des
sujets qui sont difficiles à aborder
voilà et aujourd'hui c'est plus une
censure effectivement qui vient
forcément je mens duo de deux cores
institué deux voilà qu'on peut il va
retrouver foi des autorités morales de
l'église du parti communiste ceci de
cela il ya plus d autorité morale là et
c'est le corps qui génère un peu ce
avoir peur de froisser et ou en tout cas
je
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
apprendre à être au fond c'est dans la
vie parce que sinon il n'ya pas y a pas
de débat possible à la discussion si on
supporte que des gens qui ont exactement
les mêmes du dégoût je ne vois pas
comment la vie est tout simplement même
possible parce que même quand la rue ce
n'est pas aux exercices de l'espèce
gressier esprit qui souhaite la
meilleure des actuels ont présidé au
vent c'est là
et la contradiction s'explique aussi le
piano qui est intéressant c'est le
remplacement aussi de l'aspiration à
l'universel qui était au coeur de
déshumanité par une espèce de pensée
tribale où chacun pense à ses
souffrances et selon son passé de
victimes c'est à dire les femmes les
femmes penser à se penser en tant que
victime du patriarcale et les noirs en
tant que victimes de l'esclavagé etc etc
et chacun est dans sa petite case et
finalement on aboutit à la perte de
l'universel qui paiement fondement d
humanité de notamment les études de
lettres ou de philosophie qui est quand
même l'idée de sortir de son
individualité pour aspirer à une
condition humaine commune et ça c'est
mon avis très dangereux alors je ne fais
pas de sexisme je vous donne la parole
alexandre simplement quelques réponses à
notre question twitter d'abord la
réponse elle même global craignez-vous
une importation en france du
politiquement correct venue des états
unis
vous êtes deux tiers est le craindre à
dire oui c'est une crainte citoyens
payeurs nous dit le politiquement
correct est une invitation au mensonge
c'est cet intéressant comme idée
d'ailleurs on y reviendra nicole ce
politiquement correct devient
insupportable on vit maintenant
pardonnez moi j'ai un petit problème tu
as well as envie maintenant dans un
monde où on ne peut plus rien dire
blueberry cake c'est son surnom le
politiquement correct vient du fait
qu'on a fait passer les minorités au
dessus de la majorité dans l'ordre des
priorités politiques maurice ça fait des
décennies qu'on vit ce politiquement
correct on y est habitués et nicole
quand seuls les minorités peuvent
s'exprimer
où est la démocratie et la liberté
d'expression qui est pourtant dans les
droits de l'homme
alexandre vous avez la parole la
minorité masculine va s'exprimer j'ai
failli me sentir discriminés
non c'est compliqué comme problème les
ce que ça vient ça vient de loin le
sentiment que ça donne comme ça moi je
suis pas un expert du sujet donc se
montrer prudents de compétence là dessus
mais gentiment que ça donne c'est qu'en
fait c'est un peu cette espèce de
vengeance du faible dire que quelque
part ces espèces de de monter en
pression de deux courants
identitaire communautaires qui viennent
à un moment donné faire irruption comme
ça et qui au nom d'une problématique
d'une forme d'injustice du ressenti de
quelque chose et tout d'un coup ce
espèce de faiblesse devient une force
contre 1 contre un système en moyenne
pression et c'est vrai qu'avec un plus
un langage utilisé qui est difficilement
contestable par ce qui veut dire
attendez il faut prendre de la distance
et votre clown est pas raisonnable
enfin soyons sérieux c'est pratiquement
impossible tous ces récits terres 10 je
prends un exemple sur un surveillant
tous les débats télévisés pu faire où il
y avait des pâtes que des féministes
comme vous mais parfois certaines
féministes un peu agressive ou
globalement en tant que mâle blanc voilà
j'ai à dire hétérosexuels mais bon c'est
pas le sujet mais je n'avais pas le
droit de parler quoi donc on est on est
tout d'un coup enfermé dans un rôle avec
une impossibilité à faire valoir un
point de vue qui augmentera très
inclusif et très engagée sur mais je
suis pas audible voilà donc cette espèce
de dérive la salle même un peu le
sentiment comme ça il ya la vengeance du
faible qu'il dit voilà moi je suis dans
ma catégorie et c'est pas faire je suis
pas représentatif et je vais y aller ça
c'est un vrai sujet de fond qu'il faudra
essayer de voir abordés et ça a été très
bien décrit a longtemps je pense par
exemple bouquin d'alain minc en 2003 qui
parlait de la tire unis s'étaient pas la
thyroïde est susceptible comme l'avait
titre à une rente hebdomadaire il ya
quelques semaines c'était la tyrannie
des minorités ils ont été également
voilà cette espèce de capacité de
quelques-uns vraiment au nom d'une cause
totalement exclusive est particulière à
tout d'un coup faire un flux et les
choses et ça c'est un sujet qu'on sait
aujourd'hui qu'on sait pas appréhendé
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est la
tyrannie du politiquement correct avec
les débats qu'on peut pas ouvrir
on l'a vu je prends je lui file y avait
là dessus sur les problématiques de
d'immigration d'islam
il a fallu attendre que le sang coule
beaucoup pour que tout d'un coup on
puisse dire des choses qui ne vous
assimile pas au front national pas et
encore répondre parce que ce que notre
internaute qui dit c'est une invitation
mensonge
oui c'est sûr puisque le modding grec
c'est finalement de refuser de nommer
les choses parce qu'on estime que nommer
les choses va conduire à une forme de
rejet des répercussions terribles réel
et je pense qu'il ya là on est vraiment
le coeur du sujet c'est de dire qu'il ya
un continuum entre les violences
verbales et les violences physiques qui
s'en prennent aux individus et je crois
que là c'est le meut sujet sur le
féminisme c'est à dire de dire que c'est
la même chose de dire une parole
agressif c'est la même chose qu'un acte
je pense qu'il faut et on a un problème
de hiérarchie en disant que non la
parole ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
l'appareil que l'acte et dire des choses
c'est parfois que ne mène pas forcément
à des actions et en espèces de
traumatisme comme ça en dix ans
finalement c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
confié mais plein de limites à la
liberté d'expression dans l'espace
public ça en lisant
finalement il ya ce qu'on appelle
l'incitation à la haine par exemple qui
est très utilisé en disant voilà c'est à
dire les choses ça va forcément conduire
des gens à se conduire de façon
agressive et c'est moi je crois que
parfois c'est complètement décor et
décorrélés il payant des gens
extrêmement violent qui parle
extrêmement bien et c est l inverse est
possible aussi donc
et je crois que si je continue à me l'a
entre toutes les violences nous empêche
d'appréhender vraiment le réel alors
pour revenir dans des choses un peu très
concrètes
il ya un autre article était celui de
dans le figaro magazine le week-end
dernier
ce livre qui est faite a été de nos
censeurs gérald smith qui vit en
caroline du nord et qui décrit un peu le
papier titré quand l'amérique devient
folle alors par exemple ces histoires je
crois que vous y fait aussi allusion au
génie
des recours à des contrôles et sparadrap
la couleur des sparadraps pour dire
qu'ils sont pas adaptés à la couleur de
peau et ce qu'il faut un sourire et ce
qu'il faut parce qu'en france qu'on
prend on aboutit à un paradoxe qui est
comme il faut être sauf qu'il faut pas
faire de mal en fait on en arrive à des
rapports extrêmement violent on vous
interdit très violemment y compris
physiquement parfois on vous interdit de
parler d'abord des effectivement le réel
de dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
objectives nadjar disent qu'ils trouvent
une phrase un paradoxe de cette douceur
qui est prôné au nom de voilà de la
protection des victimes et en fait on
nous agresse nous on nous empêche de
parler un peu la phrase que si tu te
jordy smith qui est paraît-il la phrase
brandi tout de suite c'est stop hiaumet
king mis en cause furent tout ça tout de
suite je pense que c'est très très grave
parce que je pense que trump est le
résultat de sa sert le trump et la
némésis du comme l'édifice de croûtes
très bien et la némésis du prix du coup
moins correct aux etats unis c'est à
dire c'est les gens qui on a eu
tellement ras le bol qu'on parle des
toilettes
on me et transsexuels etc il en parlait
beaucoup dans ses meetings en trinquant
le féminisme radical tout ça et le
résultat c'est trump c'est à dire le
contraire du politiquement correct un
type qui dit en a marre moi je vais vous
dire la vérité parce que les autres ne
veulent pas dire je vais vous dire tout
ce que les autres refusent de dire et
quand on a trop politiquement correct on
aboutit à 30 dont moi je dis attention
mais chez nous c'est que si on importe
le politiquement correct des états unis
on va apporter aussi son son résultat et
la vengeance du politiquement correct ce
sera un espèce de trump qui nous dire ah
bah voilà moi je vais dire la vérité est
tout acquis s'embarrassera plus du tout
de former de futurs électeurs
et moi je souhaiterais donc nous voilà
et les faits lui c'est le grand verre
dépoli à interdire naissance il répond
le coup fait non à ce que dirait c'est
que j'ai l'impression que ça va comme
idée c'est que s'amorçait les normands
la société sert chaque année dans une
case et même l'homme blanc finalement il
ya dans une case enfin il vient aussi
victime c'est aussi ça va avec la
victimisation qui est assez
insupportable de tout eh oui ça
encourage mensonge par exemple sur
l'histoire vous vais devoir tout le
temps chaque minorité ou les noirs ou
les arabes ecsta à son pan d'histoire et
le but n'est pas d'avoir d'aller vers la
justesse et l'analyse la plus pondéré la
plus honnête des faits énoncés de ces
d'être victime n'a plus de victimes
possible tout est trompé la confiance ça
conforte chacun en fait dans sa
faiblesse en fait la falaise devient un
projet or c'est pas un projet il faut
dépasser ses faiblesses l'on a tous
fièrement il faut vivre avec les autres
et quelque part il faut être un peu plus
fort il faut voilà il faut quitte à se
faire mal elle est allée au delà et je
pense qu'on peut pas encourager
s'agirait en tout cas c'est une tendance
de société qui si elle s'installait chez
nous déjà qu'elle est un peu là qu'on a
du mal à voir tous les débats ce serait
vraiment très près à main il
préjudiciable pour les prochaines
générations
il ya un autre aspect des efforts aussi
beaucoup de mal à le transmettre aux
jeunes ils n'ont jamais entendu qu'il
faut faire des exercices il faut
travailler et il faut prendre du plaisir
lassé voilà le chouchoutage il faut pas
les laisser porter malheur c'est
terrible parce que on aboutit
effectivement au résultat inverse agents
oui je pense que la première adversité
réseau et vous écroulez c'est ça le
risque c'est sympa que le matin ne se
fera pas de cadeau donc autant être il
ya un autre aspect c'est celui de la
d'aussi de la discrimination positive
tribune ce matin dans le figaro sur le
procès qui est fait toujours harvard
contre eux harvard par des étudiants
américains d'origine asiatique qui
disent les tout ce qui est aux
discriminations positives quotas dans
les universités en fait on est
discriminée parce que compte tenu de nos
résultats on devrait avoir plus de
chance et de d'entrée dans les
universités
or on et discriminés par rapport aux aux
américains d'origine hispanique ou ou
noirs américains c'est on le voit à
l'écran hmmm l'étude a été poussé assez
loin puisqu'ils disent qu'ils ont 25% de
chances d'être admis à vars alors qu'à
compétences égales il doit en avoir 35 %
s'ils étaient blancs 75% s'il était
paniqué 95% s'il était noir dépensé à
une étude de cas les faits le le
sociologue gérald bronner sur la fait la
différence
enfin à quel point les discours pouvait
influencer selon les milieux les
les enfants d'immigrés par l'ampli
disais que en effet les enfants issus de
communautés asiatiques réussi c'est
beaucoup mieux à l'école que les enfants
issus de communautés par exemple arabo
musulmane il faisait parce qu'il avait
un discours justement victimaire dans
certaines communautés qui encouragé
certains enfants a finalement à ne pas
travailler parce que c'est souvent la
lettone des tests et un racisme d'état
la société ne veut pas de nous nouons
n'est pas encouragé tandis que dans des
pains de la communauté asiatique il y
avait un discours beaucoup plus sur
l'effort sur l'idée de réussite mérite
était donc ils disaient voilà en fait
c'est aussi une question de discours
milieux sociaux équivalents même avec
même problème de déracinement de
l'immigration et c'est certain ils
réussissent mieux parce qu'un discours
qui les portent vers la réussite
et alors qu'un autre discours qui les
entretient dans la victimisation et des
et voilà il faut faire attention au cul
pour clore le débat aucune vertu
finalement à trouver à cette politique
qui est de longue date maintenant aux
états unis de discrimination positive
l'adisq island amazit il veut pour les
femmes par exemple moi je me souviens là
tous les débats autour des quotas dans
le parti socialiste c'est vrai c'est
c'est complexe parce que si à un moment
donné vous mettez pas de quotas vous
savez on a deux faces du tout rien ne se
passe mais ça doit être des mesures
transitoires
il faut effectivement pas que ça
devienne un principe comme la parité
pour moi la parité c'est absurde parce
que à certains moments pourquoi pas
mettre un quota de 75% même deux femmes
allez hop pendant trois ans on va mettre
75 % pour rééquilibrer mais après on
s'arrête mais ça n'est il faut pas
essentialiser justement ça c'est une
mesure technique installé de façon
transitoire assumer pas mais mais pour
les hommes et les femmes par exemple
mais alors si on rentrait dans l'épreuve
à exemple et qu'on s'était alors là
c'est mon avis
en fait ce serait beaucoup plus les
médias j'entendais ce matin que la loi
montée qui m'a date maintenant d'une
dizaine d'années me semble-t-il qui
astique tu sais quoi quasiment 40% de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
eh ben on est un pays ou alors pour le
coup on a décollé bien août sur les
concentrations de grandes entreprises
enfin aller vite sur ce sujet on va
respecter la loi donc si on la sait le
palois on n'aurait pas respecté c'est
très bien on est à un moment il faut on
a des meilleurs en europe le problème
c'est qui encore un très grand décalage
par rapport au comex au comité direction
et que le législateur elle sans qu il va
peut-être falloir s'en occuper de ce qui
pour le coup serait catastrophique parce
qu'un considération c'est une chose et
un comité direction qui est fondée par
des formules
c'est l'expérience opéra qui compte et
là vous n'allez pas la fabrique et on va
pas la force et on a vu dans la fonction
publique ce que ça veut dire parfois
fait remonté trop vite
un sondage ans pour occuper des postes
en tant que femme il ya eu quelques
catastrophes donc et y compris dans la
hotte fait aux autres entreprises
françaises avec parfois certains postes
d'une part des femmes qui n'ont pas été
pas bien préparé on pense au nucléaire
allez on passe au péage urbain
même si tout ça est passionnant alors
faudra-t-il bientôt payer pour circuler
en voiture dans les centres des grandes
villes c'est prévu par le projet de loi
orientation d'orientation sur les
mobilités c'est le sait son nom les
villes de plus de 5000 habitants
pourront faire payer l'accès à leurs
centres villes c'est une information qui
a été donnée par le site contexte ce
matin et qui a été confirmé par le
ministre françois de rugy
alors évidemment c'est la lutte contre
l'engorgement et la pollution qui est
mise en avant est ce pour autant une
bonne idée
les maires concernés ne semble pas se
précipiter on va écouter d'abord d' le
premier adjoint d'anne hidalgo
il était ce matin l'invité du talk du
figaro avec yves thréard 7e manuel
grégoire on comprend ce dont il ne veut
pas qu'est-ce qui nous montre ses péages
urbains à londres ou à singapour pour
prendre les deux exemples les plus
célèbres
ce qu'il rapporte beaucoup d'argent qui
sont extrêmement discriminant et qu'à
long terme il ne règle pas le problème
environnemental c'est à dire que on
assiste à une décrue de la voiture
pendant là au début de la mise en place
et puis peut-être petit à petit et donc
à la fin il ya toujours autant de
circulation et on a profondément grever
le pouvoir d'achat des particuliers
bonne idée ou pas l'exemple moi j'aurais
tendance à dire si c'est uniquement une
idée comme ça qui sort du chapeau il
faut reprendre la phrase emmanuel macron
il faut arrêter d'emmerder pour le coup
les automobilistes voulaient des
français ça c'est ça c'est clair
après le problème de la du trafic dans
les villes il est considérable mais
c'est plus généralement preuve de la
ville donc il faut un moment donné
essayer d'avoir une vision sur ces
sujets qui est pas une vision gadget en
dur on a une réponse comme ça c'est bien
souvent oubliés comme la gratuité des
métros très bien c'est peut-être une
bonne idée en soi
je suis même plutôt favorable à la
gratuité des transports en commun mais
il faut repenser les choses dans leur
globalité
j'ai vraiment donné que comme enrobé
l'homme dans sa ville à laquelle ville
vous
nous comment est-ce qu'on se met dans
sur un schéma moyen long terme comment
est ce qu'on peut vous répondre mais la
pollution elle est là tous les jours
mais n'y at oui on y chante c'est à dire
oui mais non pas parce que je pense que
ce qui a été dit ce matin par l'adjoint
au maire de la ville de paris et sur mon
fondées parce que j'ai dis pas ça par
hasard il faut pas faire n'importe quoi
d'une part puis deuxièmement il faut pas
faire des mesures qui vont parier
l'épreuve de fond il faut penser les
aménagements général en amont des
grandes villes pour pouvoir stocker les
voitures il faut repenser les transports
urbains parce que pardon apparition pas
humain c'est pas sympa transporter de
paris dans ces conditions là il faut
redonner du nom de la fiabilité du
confort voilà une fois que vous avez
tout fait tout ça vous pouvez commencer
à ma des systèmes un peu coercitif parce
qu'il ya des alternatives
voilà et là on fait on met du coercitif
on met du punitif et puis après on dit
bon mais on verra plus tard pour le port
le port la réflexion intelligente et
sion ou une fois mais c'est des cons
sujet il faut que les politiques se
mettre autour de la table autour de l'an
mil de france ça veut dire au moins
quatre ou cinq structures
administratives et politiques
donc c'est très compliqué mais sinon on
continuera à faire ce qu'on fait c'est
dire n'importe quoi
genia la question sociale aussi c'est à
dire que c'est quand même une réforme
pensé par des urbains pour des zurbains
on al'impression parce que les gens qui
réfléchissent dans les ministères sont
des gens qui se font livrer leur course
par par par chauffeur über des livres ou
enfin nous parle des livres ou et qui se
déplace uniquement en vtc ou en
trottinette électrique
je viens ils sont pas concernés par les
millions de français qui généralement
sont des classes sociales plus
inférieure qui prennent la voiture et
culture et nature la voiture est devenue
quelque chose pour les pauvres
c'était avant l'averse c'était une
marque de richesse aujourd'hui c'est une
marque plutôt de beauté quand on est
riche on n'a plus de voiture parce qu'on
vit dans une grande métropole et qu'on
déplace avec
des outils privé mais voilà et je pense
que donc il faut absolument qui
n'interdit vie si c'est pour créer
davantage de fracture entre la métropole
et la banlieue c'est pas une bonne chose
et chaud qui adorent et d'autres choses
prioritaires notamment à paris par
exemple supprimer les autocars
touristique qui polluent énormément qui
font du trafic et un énorme comme ça a
été fait ailleurs dans d'autres villes
notre exemple rome par exemple supprimés
voilà on les maintient failli les
touristes prennent le métro comme tout
le monde donc si on marche on fait du
bien aussi mais mais je trouve que c'est
hallucinant qu'on ne prenne pas où on ne
s'attaque pas par exemple aux autocars
et on s'attaque d'abord aux voitures des
gens qui vont travailler les voitures
dans paris cécile sujet il est parfait
si les paccots dans paris parce que la
la la la face au juste c'est que la la
le célibat il est cent mille habitants
des cinq mille habitants de retrait fait
le même pari on n'est même pas dans les
métropoles on est très très on n'est pas
en fait il ya une centaine de vins vous
avez raison le rapport est donc le sujet
n'est pas il n'est pas parisien en fait
puis à paris dont ne veulent pas donc ce
sens se produira pas vraiment up qui a
suivi sur les zones d'émission jeu
comment ça s'appelle les zones à faibles
émissions les autres c'est gérable
uniquement effectivement s'il ya une
offre suffisante de transport en commun
est ce qui est pas du tout cas plein de
villes de 100 mille cinq cent mille
habitants donc c'est ça devient c'est
assez pour les mettre à ces
problématiques
c'est pas un luxe les gens ne prennent
pas prennent pas leur voiture pour aller
travailler et si oui non mais c'est pas
c'est pas par plaisir si effectivement
il n'y a pas de moyen de transport
alternatif et si on
gr pas autrement effectivement la
relation des territoires entre l'habitat
et les lieux de travail enfin c'est vrai
que ces deux-là de la folie et puis et
puis c'est un cercle vicieux tant qu'il
n'y a pas de transports en commun on
prend la voiture donc on prend la
voiture on ne développe pas les
transports en commun donc bon c'est vrai
que c'est un problème global c'est
extrêmement complexe il suffit pas de
dire bon on va faire payer et puis ça va
être résolue certainement pas
effectivement c'est injuste et
probablement inefficace et bien voilà le
ps va enterrer en tout cas parfois le
vue je veux juste quelques réactions
alors vous êtes cij par exemple on
supprime les services à la campagne on
pousse les gens à s'entasser en ville et
après on taxe ceux qui prennent leur
voiture
pourquoi ne pas arrêter de tout
centraliser dans les villes et de
remettre les transports en commun des
transports en commun à la campagne dit
encore sich blueberry cake toujours et
si on repenser l'aménagement du
territoire des petites villes moyennes
qui meurt et enfin nicole j'habite à 20
minutes de nice mais je n'ai pas de
transports en commun
pourtant ce n'est pas ce n'est pas plus
le rural comment fait-on voilà c'est dit
voilà la question qui reste ouverte
n'est-elle beaucoup beaucoup à tous les
quatre merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
et vous avez rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]